what are we looking at so it's early
days but i want to go back to the start
of this game and just talk through what
has happened so far because as simon
mentioned it's really exciting really
dramatic if we pull up the board we're
only on move nine right now but if we go
all the way back to the start to the
starting position magnus with white
opens with his king's pawn and here
anish giri practicing what he preaches
playing the sicilian night off the
opening with which he made a very
successful chessable course and uh here
we see the open sicilian we see black's
knight coming out hitting the central
pawn white's knight defending and here
is the night off black's little pawn
push guarding the key b5 square as we
see later another purpose behind it and
here magnus playing
a well-known move but maybe not the most
common move white's rook just sliding
across one square and it looks like it
breaks all sorts of all sorts of rules
white's king cannot castle on the side
now but the whole idea is to push a pawn
forward and
i've actually played this one myself a
few times online it's very tricky some
very specific ideas behind it
uh the idea is to push this pawn and
therefore giri said no pushing harry the
h-born stopping and uh any pawn push
controlling the g4 square and now after
a bishop came forward we see this
position and magnus has just made the
committal decision of capturing this
black knight so now black has the bishop
pair but black has a bit of an odd
structure and black's king is likely to
remain in the center forever
and that being said what is white's rook
doing on the g1 square and does white
have time to maybe move the queen out of
the way and then just get castled as
quickly as possible if white's king can
kind of shuffle away to this side of the
ward nice and safe behind some pawns
then magnets will be very very happy but
uh aneesh has the long-term potential of
the bishops and despite black's weird
pawn structure i like the fact that he's
ready to maybe play on this side of the
board later maybe ready to push this one
down the board as well flexible for
black
yeah what do you guys think yeah very
very interesting position um
it resembles like a bit of a classical
sicilian i'd say um you get this this
exchange that magnus has played quite
often but to my eyes at least it looks
like black might have a good version of
it um both kings are kind of in some
danger in these positions because the
black king can't really castle kingside
is too open the white king can't castle
kingside
so that leaves the queen side and
there's all sorts of things going on on
the queen side so
that means it's going to be a very
exciting game lots of peace on the board
with two exposed kings uh in the middle
so uh this is this is i think gonna be
very very interesting and i mean ivanka
i mean would you take white or black in
the current position i find these
positions so complicated because you
know it looks uh on pawn first
impressions that maybe white is doing
quite well after all the black king is
going to be saddled in the center of the
board but then on the other hand when
you kind of try to go deeper you realize
that it's not that easy for white to
attack black's pawn shield and also if
you do over stretch then suddenly the
black bishop pair would also come into
play and so it's almost i know it's not
quite called the hedgehog but this is
kind of like a hedgehog strategy you
know it curls up into a little ball and
says come attack me and then i'll show
my spikes i
i have to say i think it's very balanced
and i would just say
i sit on the fence i don't know what's
happening
yeah that's clear absolutely whenever
you read these books uh chess books
which uh you know go back if you ever
see if you ever got a chess book
probably older than like five years they
don't allow it anymore if you ever see
the uh assessment unclear that means
that the author either doesn't like the
position of the opening he's
recommending so if it's like winning
with the i don't know winning with the
english opening and he gives the line
where he leaves it is unclear it means
he doesn't like it but he can't say it
or it just means he doesn't know what's
going on so you do get that sometimes in
the old chess books unclear uh
assessment of the position because it's
just like well why i don't know what's
going on
before computers could assess well
probably going back more than more than
five years actually yeah 15 years or
something you're right though simon
we're just gonna have to call this one
unclear and uh now magnus has pushed his
pawn forward very natural the whole idea
is that black at some point wants to put
his pawn on the e6 square he needs to
somehow just kind of keep this uh keep
this pawn formation intact as your vanco
mentioned it's a bit like a hedgehog
where kind of these are the kind of
prickles um what do you call them spikes
spikes spikes and they will prick you if
you go too far forward but you want to
undermine this structure they control
everything these pawns they control all
these squares and it's just hard to kind
of break forward here with white but
magnus's idea is to destabilize these
pawns if they ever do advance so um
instead of that instead of committing
anish does just bring his night out i
like this idea because now after the
night trade
we do talk about bishop pairs and
bishops when they are as a pair they
gain strength the more pieces that leave
the board they'll have more open
diagonals if there are more trades more
exchanges but magnus has used the
opportunity to bring his queen into the
center of the board and now he's ready
sorry dave what about rook b8 here i
mean my first thought is as black i want
to get the queens off
which i don't normally like doing
but if i can get the queen
ah i'm getting old you know
it's those bishops and you know i think
white always has the better attacking
chances so my first thought would be
like get that queen to that lovely
square get the queens off and um
then i'm feeling quite safe as black
i've got loads of pawns in the center
got the two bishops i'm actually maybe
preferring my my position slightly so
just just like maybe brook b8s and i did
really clever simon as well because
you're kind of making a mockery of white
putting his rook on this square if the
rook wasn't on the square white could
just step back and say okay no trade for
you but unfortunately this rook would be
hanging
so yeah you can pretty much get the
queens off by force yeah with your move
simon yeah i mean i it just looks it
looks like the you know rather than
allow
your king is quite weak you can
obviously do maybe there's more
aggressive things i mean it's not really
me is it giving that movie i'm kind of
like what what's going on you're getting
inside anisha's head and niche loves
getting the queens off the board
i'm playing like the player not like the
position so i'm just getting those and
these fives coming towards me
i mean could you push the pawn two
squares as well i mean is that is that
okay now i'm kind of trying to make up
for it yeah i'm trying i'm trying to
like
i've done my normal move now i'm gonna
do a stupid move like e5 because i you
know i kind of do want to get my dart
squad bishop in and
you i don't know if i play that though
but i mean uh sure i mean leave some
light squares behind uh that white
knight can maybe use later on
it's impossible not i mean i've got to
follow up with the bishop coming to h6 i
mean this is the only way to make this
uh idea for example if white
chooses a bad square then at least you
create a pin you get your bishop into
the game
yeah makes some sense
yeah yeah somehow like i like both those
ideas you know you know your
your second one you know the pawn push
you know it does ask white to to solve
some problems on the dark squares yeah
and uh
come out as well don't i mean exactly
i mean even in the position of the
bishop here the queen but yeah they're
both they're very different approaches
aren't they what's the niche going to
pick your banker is he going to go he's
going to go for your first one i love
your first one you know when you
suggested it and you're like get the
queens off i was like
that is it simon you spit the nail on
the head david what do you reckon he's
going to do i agree i think we'll see
this move but maybe we can see the
stockfish evaluation simon has mentioned
two very tempting moves there moving the
rook across or pushing the pawn up to
immediately kick away this queen
oh which one is anish going to play big
big question right now we'll see
i'll just check the computer the
community goes no none of those ideas
okay right
fair enough it just doesn't like any of
my suggestions
the structure very solid as we mentioned
earlier black controls all the squares
in his half of the board now
and uh magnus i have no doubt wants to
castle queen side at some point and
we'll see a lot of
uh tension ahead cool this one's shaping
up nicely i have a feeling we're gonna
see a decisive result it's so imbalanced
right now with the pieces and with the
pawn structure ah how cool sounds like
it's going to be a cool game there's
game two between magnus carlos and anish
geary they are tied after the first game
young christophe duda and hans niemann
we're all waiting for updates it's
technical issues with that game one
so i'm not 100 sure what's happening
because it is uh
it's not possible to actually
look at that game
because
well because of the power going out of
duda's computer
um we need our people on the ground to
keep us updated yeah we do i think it's
microsoft is just doing its normal
updates
it's still going on 10 minutes half an
hour later you know update to windows 6
oh sorry carrick
just nothing oh he's gone bro
it's your move you must be happy late
though because now when the queen tries
to offer itself up for a trade well you
know magnus has that one move to preempt
it
and you guys asked for it there's some
updates on the ground from miami the
game has finished game one between duda
and niman and we now have an interview
with hans neiman after that game let's
hear from the american
describe it well it's completely [ __ ]
ridiculous that the the laptop is just
running out of power and uh because lata
runs out of power of course he has all
the time to think in the world to find
all the best moves and he has 20 seconds
and then he sits there for five minutes
gets the final best move so the fact
that the laptop runs out of power
completely threw me off and it's just
completely ridiculous it should not be
happening like plug the [ __ ] laptop
in and uh i shouldn't be losing a game
because uh
uh
like he gets five extra minutes to think
and finds the best moves and okay can i
recover psychology psychologically but
matches it over thank you
that's a brutal
interview hans nimon super angry he ends
up losing
game one against young christoph duda
saying himself that it's uh down to
those five minutes the young christopher
judah was able to think about the game
and find the best moves um carl you sure
he lost he didn't say he lost there
i i he never mentioned it he said losing
yeah
losing a position i wasn't sure if he
lost
him
we should apologize for the language we
should have had some beeps in there uh
but we can also understand hans niemann
being super frustrated because uh
technical issues uh when the game
started he uh wasn't able to save that
draw
and a win for young christoph duda in
that first game
i think these players now will have 10
minutes before game 2 starts can you
somehow understand the frustration
though david for hans yeah we've all
been there
everyone here in the panel probably
everyone at home as well when we've lost
a difficult game especially when we knew
we were doing well especially when we
felt we shouldn't lose the game um yeah
it can be heartbreaking and we all react
in different ways when i was younger i
used to be very much like a hands very
angry used to blame the world everything
i think maybe players with more
experience they realize okay you got to
channel it correctly you've got to focus
you can't let it affect you too much
still three big games ahead but uh yeah
understandable from hans and he'll
bounce back and he did say match isn't
over it definitely isn't still three
rapid games to go in their match today
and he can still strike back and the
rain is starting again in oslo we can
hear him pouring on the roof and moves
are coming out in magnus crossing
against unity game two move your
vancouver is a huge move you know and uh
that is a very thematic uh sacrifice
actually jumping in with the knight to
the center of the board just to open up
lines to attack the black king in the
middle
and uh well
i thought the black king was safe as
houses but uh it's not now yeah we must
add here that this sacrifice the
computer hates it it's very typical um
wow we can hear thunder above us it's
like oh the god of thunder has arrived
here annoying that's great timing yeah
he slams that move on the board and you
get the lightning
as well the norwegian magnus thor slams
his knights on that square and that's
when we're here we need chess with the
sound effects
and uh let's jump in because this night
sacrifices your vanco mentions it's very
thematic it's very typical in this
opening the sicilian the whole idea is
to open up lines there is also a direct
threat of knight takes pawn defended by
the white queen and that would be deadly
to the black king so the acid test of
the sacrifice is to accept it capture
this knight and after magnus recaptures
firstly an attack on the bishop wherever
the bishop goes i guess magnus's idea is
to give a check and problems for the
black king do you run and try to hide
for example you could step into the
center but now white's attack will be
very much long-term white can simply
just develop pieces and the king will
never really find safety black is a
piece up but this bishop is blocked this
bishop is still at home asleep so decent
practical compensation here
the problem as well for black is that
how do you block this check if you don't
run away with your king the only kind of
safe block is to move your bishop but
now you have to worry about white taking
this pawn for example utilizing a pin
along the e file black's bishop cannot
capture the white queen
you're also attacking this rook in the
corner i'm not really sure what the
follow-up is here for magnus if black's
rook just moves out the way uh to any
safe square but it does look mightily
scary and the thunder's still raging
above us the rain's still pouring and
that would be the case for the black
king here
all of the elements facing uh against it
right now it looks very very scary and
giri yet to accept the sacrifice if you
don't accept this knight sacrifice what
else do you do this pawn is under fire
do you really have to just move your
bishop to defend this pawn a bit of a
sad move to play
i guess magnus could even leave his
knight here but at the very least he
could retreat it to maybe this square or
this square and the game would go on
what do you guys think take that knight
or leave it
okay don't judge me but i'm a chicken i
don't like playing with my king so
exposed and especially when i look at
the clock situation you know ten minutes
not that much time to navigate such a
minefield
i'd develop the bishop okay you would
ignore the gift the gift of a free piece
yes and what about you simon
i'm the same i i actually hate being
attacked i love i love giving away
people you want to be white here simon i
don't want to be honest
yeah exactly i just i just wouldn't want
to be attacked like this so i would i
whoa oh
that's scary
wow
simon
no i'm wondering that as well but we'll
do all that one later shall we oh are
you guys scared of the thunder i'm okay
but not normally but when it's raging
right above us yeah that was very close
with so many like technical stuff around
us were you also not taught by your
parents you know when there was thunder
and lightning raging above you run and
you unplug yeah every technical stuff
yeah and here we are with everything
going on might be our final guys yeah
it's been a pleasure
can we now have a serious drink before
we go
but i just have to say you know we were
discussing about how we were just not
brave enough to accept the the sacrifice
on offer
but aneesh he is sharing some serious
courage because he's taken that piece
yeah but it's slightly worrying for me
that he took the piece and then he
stopped
surely you have to calculate whether you
can take the piece and uh and then work
out the details later but aneesh
closing his eyes there yeah is he still
in opening preparation oh no no you
don't think so no way
no he's calculating he can't be he is
the master of the night off really that
posture says to me he thinks
plenty of times normally when he's
looking down off to the side or not at
the board
he's trying to remember so isn't this
normally where he makes a move about his
hands now
he'll do that
the magic move with his uh you know i
don't know we've never worked how he did
it there's dozens of cameras watching
him this time though so we'll figure out
if he's uh using his magic wand to make
those pieces move
but uh yeah in this position if you do
know what you're doing then you take the
knight then uh you kind of continue
playing you move your black light squad
bishop out the way now you're a piece up
you defend but
if you're just kind of freestyling if
you're just working things out for the
first time you don't take that white
knight as you guys mentioned you just
move your bishop the game goes on
you continue as normal and it's still
balanced but
i don't know i have a feeling just the
way he played that black rook move came
one move later than we were expecting he
may kind of pushed all his pawns to the
sixth rank earlier just the way he's
doing things i have a feeling anish
kind of half knows what he should be
doing here but can't quite remember
and that's often a tricky spot to be in
you know what the computer says you know
what the computer recommends you know
the evaluation it might say 0.0 or hear
plus one for black but you can't
remember the exact moves and magnus
carson's ghost has uh came out the
picture there to have a look i don't
know if you saw that as well
i felt like there was like some matrix
reloaded thing
yeah griefy stuff going on the thunder
here in oslo's affecting the connection
well talking about connection so uh we
did have a very interesting result
victory and young christophed and hans
niemann in game one and ended with a win
for young christoph duda after almost 10
minutes where they could think about the
game because his computer ran out of
power they restarted the game and duda
won it we heard hans niemann he was so
angry let's also hear from young
christoph duda
quite the drama unfolding there young
system how would you describe the
situation yeah the situation was uh for
sure very unfortunate um
luckily i mean it didn't have particular
consequences the position was kind of
technical nature and
actually it didn't matter that much uh i
mean haha how much time
we've got obviously it was my advantage
because i was loving the time but
at least it wasn't like you know
i couldn't couldn't find force force win
because there was none of course in such
position
so um yeah and my position was i mean so
nice you know i i tried to be fair and
not to calculate too much i mean when
when my computer went down but um it was
just too interesting to me you know and
i had to uh just attempting to analyze
it because um
because it was kind of um
for sure it was horrible for him but i
mean it was
also in a way you know very
very interesting for me to find if i
have any real chances actually to pull
it off
did you ever consider offering a draw
um no i mean i had such a nice position
i mean i didn't risk it at all so i'm
not ready
thank you
thank you
dramatic game one for duda and nieman
ending up with a win four do that and
game two for these two will start
shortly we are following game two with
magnus carlsen and
anish geary and uh magnus is uh down to
uh a little bit less time on the clock
what's happening what will be the result
in this kind of game do you think
who knows like i have right now magnus
is a whole piece down he sacrificed that
night he just got one pawn in return
that's not sufficient compensation black
does have the two bishops as well if the
queen's ever come off black is just
winning
if any pieces get traded off black is
just winning so magnus needs to deliver
checkmate to win this game he needs to
get both of the white rooks kind of
lining up together attacking the black
king he needs to get the white bishop
into the game
the most obvious move in the position
might well be a mistake here um there's
just so many uh so many options for
magnus can he navigate this kind of maze
where he needs to be super accurate the
pressure is on him the onus is on magnus
right now to create something
if gary gets two moves black is just
going to consolidate his extra piece and
maybe we can jump in and try to
kind of brainstorm some ideas here while
magnus thinks what is going through the
world champion's mind
is he going to utilize this pin i
mentioned that taking this pawn
looks very tempting hitting the rook in
the corner but if the rook just moves
i'm not sure which square it should do
to this square or to this square
what is the white queen actually doing
it's a it's a problem there david that
the white pawn in the middle is not
defended anymore yeah is that the issue
you're thinking of so i mean queen takes
pawn looks so natural doesn't it you win
a pawn you create a fret you but maybe
the issue is that
if black can move this bishop and
capture the pawn it's not just winning a
pawn
it's a great defensive piece i guess
sure for example yeah the black bishop
now can slide back at some point to
block the e file also i'm a bit worried
that you take this pawn but
at some point you will have to retreat
your queen
your queen eventually will come under
fire and you've just lost two moves to
gain a pawn and
winning a pawn here is not the number
one priority it's going for checkmate
i'm also worried that the black king
will just start running away to safety
at some point just hiding on this side
of the board hiding in the corner you
have to be really accurate i think it's
maybe more of a priority to activate
this rook if you imagine this same
position but white's rook was kind of
magically on this square the two white
rooks ganged up against the black king
you'd far rather spend two moves to
tempe lining up your rooks then grabbing
a pawn so yeah that's my worry exactly
simon
what other moves could we consider here
yeah i i like your idea of just
activating the rook i mean this is such
a madness move as well because he's
really uncomfortable with playing the
position with some pieces out of play
so i i think that's what he has to do
invite this piece of the party that's it
i mean i was just thinking move the rook
up um
two two squares
move this one up yeah so maybe you could
even think about some
point of actually going bishop takes
pawn as some okay you have to be very
brave and calculate it but maybe
that's in the air as well and the whole
idea is just to line up two rooks yeah
interesting ivanka um line up the two
rooks together this is definitely uh one
idea on the cards uh you could maybe
start by moving your bishop out the way
and then stacking up your two rooks um
also at some point you could consider
pushing this pawn forward to open up the
rook this way by brute force after all
that was the reason magnus put his rook
on the square on move six normally the
idea is to open the rook up kind of uh
vertically
it's very tower-like sacrifice this
reminds me of mikhail tao the way he
played he'd often and he does go for
this which i think this is a great move
actually because uh
if the ki the black king tries to run
you you can maybe also make it a bit
annoying by checking it at some point
but it it's it's actually
quite long-term compensation as well
it's not it's not just you have to win
quickly because you're a piece down you
can also try to stop black from moving
and i think a lot of people forget about
this when when when they're playing
chess in general but when they're
sacrificing they're only thinking about
their own ideas but you've got to get
into the mind of your opponent if your
opponent doesn't have many moves you can
control the game okay so now it's really
heating up now wow very interesting he's
trying to open his rook uh on the g file
this rook is fantastic on the e-file and
i mean i would be terrified here's black
i've got to say yeah um earlier when you
guys were voting against capturing the
night i was thinking okay he has to do
it i want to see him capture but if i
were black i think i would have done the
same i would have not been tempted this
black king after all terrible piece and
you mentioned not being able to move
simon in the current position this black
bishop literally cannot move the black
queen is tied down kind of defending
that piece this black bishop is just
staring against defended pawn this these
two black rooks as well they need
several tempe several moves in order to
activate so
he has to do it actually he has to
activate his uh the rook standing on b8
because otherwise white will just uh
move the rooks and stack them up and
suddenly start attacking the bishop yeah
yeah definitely and just the g files
becoming quite dangerous that pawn
that's pushed is maybe going to move
forwards or is is so much nicer to play
these positions as white unless you're
playing a computer yes
if you're playing a computer the
computer is like stone cold but
he's gonna have to play like a computer
here right to survive here yeah so this
is also really stone cold by anish you
know just
opening up another line towards his king
i wasn't expecting that at all yeah okay
i was going to say he's going to take
here and maybe white can use this route
in as an infiltration towards the black
king but magnus says no why waste a move
kind of pushing my rook up the board
when i can simply push this pawn instead
and now the queen is the one that wants
to do the damage the queen wants to
slide across and start going towards the
black king and
i mean this is a deadly threat one more
move and black's king is in massive
trouble the only reason i don't like
this pawn push for magnus is that it
does block his own bishop simon you
mentioned maybe that squirrel was a
great one for the bishop now your
bishop's staring at your own pawn so
that's the downside so if black can
defend over the next few moves
maybe maybe he's uh he's going to
survive but
big if there
i'm not sure what black should do
so why is the computer liking it for a
niche the computer sees that black has
an extra bishop and and that's all it
sees that's all it sees
maybe it sees that black can defend for
the next 10 moves and that's the
computer's horizon it will say okay
black will merge with an extra bishop
black should be winning with best play
but remember these guys are human aneesh
he's got the psychological kind of
difficulty of having to defend against
the strongest player in the world a
really difficult position okay he moves
his rook across so now white's queen
cannot use this line
and uh any trades any rook takes pawn
would just result in black simplifying
the issue for example a capture here i
do oh sorry capture of rooks and i do
think black's king at some point will be
able to run away black will just have an
extra piece you can't afford to trade
anything off you're a piece down as
white
so um yeah maybe the computer's right
here though i don't see any follow-up
for magnus in the current position i
like anisha's last move making a catcher
here impossible or at least unattractive
if nature can uh survive this it's
brilliant because we've all said we
would hate to be facing this attack
especially from the world champion and
there's sometimes the most tricky
positions to to play right when you're
defending you're defending you're
defending if you play every move
perfectly maybe you're okay
but it's really tough to find the right
move so it's he's done so well so far
right just just to get himself uh
into a position where he's not getting
checkmated
i've highlighted the king a few times
but it does look pretty safe for now
tucked away behind its own pieces behind
his importance
yeah
certainly uh so wild and now it's up to
magnus to see whether he can generate
some play i did wonder whether in this
particular position whether magnus could
maybe start pushing
our fate your face
[Laughter]
and just kind of go hey
that's so calm isn't it it's so calm
it's not maybe the kind of thing you're
gonna do i mean this is a position where
if you haven't got an immediate move
that works yeah you gotta see what's my
opponent's next move okay he's going
he's going for immediately i wasn't
expecting this because i really like
david's idea of just trading rooks and
then kind of doing a pivot maneuver with
the king just head to the center i mean
the question is as well i mean at some
point you definitely have to start
running with your king before it's too
late but can you just capture this pawn
coolly and say no threat
the reason i don't want to run yet is
because if i run now maybe there's a
check maybe why i can grab a pawn at
least here white has two pawns for the
piece
black is still a bit stuck
but if you can for example slip in this
capture first
next move you definitely want to start
running and the key is that your bishop
defends this pawn that was captured in
that variation
okay moment of truth what is anish going
to play here big big moment if he can
defend
three or four more moves he is safe
white is running out of firepower
i like your idea david in for the penny
in for the pound as we say in the uk
take that pawn yeah might as well you've
been greedy once a niche on that square
you might as well be greedy again
he's been so brave so far that why not
continue being brave in this game um and
it also there's no if you can't see a
reason not to take pawn you take pawn
yeah especially here in a position like
this because it improves your defensive
chances
barr has definitely jumped up for aneesh
giri and in the other matches uh game
two liam is he about to make a comeback
levonoronian won game one but the bar is
over to liam's side in uh game two and
look at that young christophe duda
against hans niemann game two has
started game one ended with a dramatic
win for duda and the bar is now over to
his side i bet this is a situation where
niemont could tilt a little bit he was
so angry after losing game one yeah
definitely i mean we did see him tilt in
the ftx road to miami you know he lost a
few games and it just
went wrong for him so definitely there
is a big danger of that and he just
needs to calm down and he just needs to
just accept that you know it happened
nothing you can do about that play the
game yeah
let's see what's happened and then this
one moves on the board what will happen
in this one yeah moves on the board it's
still hard to predict this game because
there will be thrills and spills ahead
uh but i really like what anish is doing
i've got to say at least in practical uh
terms here he's just trying to force all
the pieces off the board he still has
that extra dark squared bishop doesn't
look great right now but the number one
priority is to defend and there we go
one set of rooks left the board just
three moves ago now a set of bishops
have left the board he's inching closer
to safety
and if we do a quick count white is down
a piece i think he's is it level pawns
right now
yeah level 1 so a whole piece down
yeah i mean this this could be massive
as well i mean if uh if magnus loses
what the white pieces it's it's
gonna be really hard for him to come
back
against the niche who's incredibly
strong with white pieces
big big game and
the problem with sacrificing in a
beautiful way like that is that if your
opponent often defends perfectly you can
never really see if it's a working
sacrifice or not you have to really go
with instinct and it can just backfire
you know your opponent defends you don't
get you don't get a chance you run out
of pieces and
to my eyes at least he seems to be
running out of pieces here yeah
that's why sacrifices were so beautiful
right simon because yeah he would do
this kind of thing as white and he would
make them work yeah not everyone's
capable of that so hard to do wasn't it
i mean because you have to play so
energetically you have to play
think outside the box to make these
ideas work you can't just
play natural moves sometimes because
they don't work and it seems here that
with great defense from a niche
anish must be in a great position now if
we can just keep holding on yeah
incidentally a towel was actually a
great defender for precisely the same
reason why he was a great attacker
because whilst he was
doing these fabulous attacks sometimes
they didn't work and he was forced to
defend this type of position material
down and magnus doing a good job so far
i mean we have to remember anishi's king
is still unsafe
yeah it looks like anish is about to go
on the attack though he was about to
bring his queen out uh the black queen
to line it up on the b file with the
black rook yes the black king is unsafe
but it still takes white two or three
moves to create
serious threats at least so maybe a
niche now wants to turn the tide change
the momentum and go for the white king
takes a while but uh i like the idea of
bringing black's queen out
which square will he use he was hovering
over the b6 square for black's queen
will he play that move
he's got a couple of minutes anish is he
gonna trust his instincts
i guess you still have to do a bit of
calculation here right it's not the kind
of position where you're a piece up
you've saved kind of defended everything
you can just
kind of glide to victory you still need
to be very accurate yeah i mean i'd love
to push pawn in the middle of the ball
but then a queen swing really scares me
so there are moves that are very scary
here still um that that white can play
even though you're a piece piece up it's
like
as you've said the black king is weak
um so if you could pick up the white
queen and put it on the h8 square in the
corner then it's checkmate still so
that's right still some very scary ideas
gotta watch out for that i do like uh
the move that he's thinking of playing
just uh lining up the queen and rook
together and then maybe the queen can
actually transfer herself over to the f2
square if we're lucky but i and
he's still thinking she's changed his
mind he clicked off his queen so he's
kind of uh just
yeah not trusting himself a niche right
now that's actually when the mistakes
tend to happen uh anisha's been forced
to find good moves by magnus so far just
to survive oh he's gone back to it there
we go the queen and rook do line up so a
big threat against white's b2 pawn but
that's when the mistakes often happen at
least from my experience you find all
the best moves uh when they're forced
when you have a narrow path and then as
soon as you're given three or four
choices you kind of go down the wrong uh
you go for the wrong plan or you relax
too early
and that's one pitfall that anish has to
avoid and here ivanka you mentioned
maybe the black queen can jump in
um you've got to be maybe slightly
careful here black's rook bishop maybe
they can improve
what is he going to play
he hasn't clicked on anything yet anish
giri now for the first time in a while
he's under oh yeah magnus on the clock
and that's very important the time i
mean it's not safe yet he's played very
well but it's still complicated and
you know one mistake he will lose
um i do like the idea of going active
and bringing the queen right in
but in general activity is good but
maybe a small trap if the black queen
jumps in i'm just wondering if white can
give up his rook temporarily just to
lure the black king forward and now a
double attack would win the blackrook
and you've uh gained interest in the
process you've won a piece uh with white
so all the thunder strikes above us yeah
that can only mean there's going to be
drama on the board what is anish going
to play he needs to coordinate these
three pieces he needs to get the black
king somehow over to safety towards his
pieces as well
still all three results definitely
possible despite what the evaluation bar
says yeah
definitely especially
this is the kind of move i wanted to
play because i wanted to free up the
position free up my bishop which was a
purely a defensive piece and i wanted to
try and activate it is he is he thinking
about a brie sacrifice here maybe simon
i mean queen takes this pawn yeah i mean
does he want to give the bishop away
say like you're not tal i'm tao
i mean that looks very tempting right so
suddenly the white king is the one in
all the danger there's not even a check
that you give to the black king yeah
what a turnaround that would be yeah if
black is doing the attacking
if he doesn't play that magnus if he
doesn't take this pawn what else do you
have to slide the queen the whole way
across
you threaten checkmate after all but the
black king can start its journey it can
start running i like what anish has done
he's kind of teamed up these two these
two pieces he's protected them uh so now
any check can just be met by the king
moving and look how everything's
defended for black the king defends the
bishop and the queen and rook defend
each other and this is basically forced
in this position surely black's king has
to run now
and it does white's queen steps forward
to this square
at least holding on to an idea of
capturing this pawn if the black king
continues running then queen takes pawn
is possible but
what do you guys think is there a way to
defend still one move before white can
do anything
do you run with the king do you jump in
with the black queen what do you do here
big question for niche it's kind of
tempting just to solidify the position
and play this move you know protect
everything and yeah he's gone for it
give back material just keep the king
safe
and then you know black still has the
opportunity to open up the white's king
by just uh using the a pawn as a lever
yeah he could have pushed this pawn
potentially but instead he gives a check
first
hitting the white king i think the idea
is if the king had moved to the b file
where it wanted to hide then there would
have been a sacrifice here and uh black
would have actually won on the spot
because this is a check and the white
rook would have dropped so magnus now
has been forced to put his king on a
really uh kind of ugly square in the
center of the board where it will get
hit from all sorts of angles and anish
gives a check is he going to try and
force a draw
no no come on
[Music]
okay he's he doesn't have much time on
the clock sorry yeah no i was gonna say
he can repeat the position if he brings
his queen back to this square that's the
second time we'll see that position and
it will be a draw
oh gosh okay anish second time we've
seen it now
ivanka what do you think you're gonna
say i just gonna say you know he's got
30 seconds on the clock and ideally if
he wants to keep the game alive he's
probably going to have to actually
retreat the queen back to where it came
from and then you know he's lost some
momentum some time
i think he might bail out could make an
argument for maybe giving a check i'm
not sure which square exactly when the
white king moves now you can just defend
your bishop maybe oh but he's going for
the draw niche let's go back to the
players i think we're going to see a
result if anish brings his queen back to
the f4 square
then we will see a draw magnus looking
away from the board now
he's pretty confident he saved this game
but
aneesh play for the win you won't get a
better chance against the world champion
and he takes the draw it is a draw a
dramatic game but a draw in game two
between magnus crawls and anish geary
still tied both games so far ended with
draws and oh they're actually
we haven't seen that before
discussing the game probably